foreign
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
kind of disturbed me but at the same
time I feel sorry for the individual and
I felt more Disturbed when he actually
took off this nakab that he was wearing
with the jilbab because what I saw I was
like bloody oh you looked much better
with it on than without it sure
I mean he looked much much better with
that on rather than without with it off
and we know it's Haram for a man to
dress up as a woman but I mean the
Sharia in certain circumstances could
even say you know what maybe it's better
for this man to walk around in a nekabo
jilbab then walk around in that manner
you know not much to be said but the
funny thing and the ironic thing is the
following and this is what Allah says in
Surah
and he gives a parable Allah says Allah
presents an example a man who's owned by
quarreling arguing partners and another
belonging exclusive to one man so
meaning one has multiple Masters and one
has one master are they equal in
comparison praise be to Allah but most
of them do not but most of them do not
know now when the carbender is mocking
the woman or the man who wears the
Islamic attire and a man who should be
covered up his wall we are deciding that
God Almighty knows what is best for us
we have one Lord which is Allah he tells
us what to do
and he tells us a simple dress code that
dress code doesn't change for a woman it
is that everywhere should be covered
except the hands and the face for a man
that he should obviously lower his gaze
have modesty and self internally
externally and we shall also cover from
the navel to the knee yes of course
there's a difference opinion of the
matter but in a nutshell that doesn't
change but what you see and the
performance is very ironic because when
he takes that off and steps forward he
is going from and this is very
interesting and he discourse it is Ayah
he is going from obeying one master to
now multiple Masters and if this was a
woman that's doing this the society that
she live in she lives in the liberal
Society the Western Society is going is
arguing till this day what is Modesty a
skirt fully covering her legs or is it a
skirt that's just below the knee a skirt
that's up to the knee just above the
knee a mini skirt maybe a bikini so you
can see that the moment you step out
from the harbor algor Almighty is
ordained you are bound to be enslaved to
multiple Masters he's going to tell you
no dress up like this that's the modesty
that is what morality is no no no today
it's this no tomorrow it's that you are
obeying multiple Masters now and that is
the key when I see this performance I
just feel sorry that from the Obedience
of one God you are going to go to The
Obedience of multiple masters from one
master to multiple Masters not only that
it affects your clothing but you do not
even know what to wear you don't even
know what is okay it's fashion that
dictates you so isn't it ironic that we
have a religion that is from the one
master and that one master tells us and
commands us one thing and we follow that
who can be more free than the one who
obeys that one master or like Allah says
in the Quran the one who has multiple
Masters and he doesn't know what to do
and this is the same with females and
men who are living in the society and I
used to be the byproduct of one of those
I see one of those individuals who used
to dress a certain way work extra hours
look a certain way go to the gym or
whatever it may be because I had so many
Masters to please
but I now have one master and I have one
way of living and the simple
Commandments that I obey and I found my
true Freedom when I enslave my myself to
the one who created man who deserves My
Worship and that is the true Freedom
that you will truly face and truly live
other than that you are bound to be more
bound to be enslaved and in shackles to
multiple Masters pulling you this way
and that way and you don't know what you
want and and you don't know which one to
please and you die in misery till next
time
is establishing a Masjid and a community
center if you donate to build this
Masjid Allah build a house for you in
Jannah with bricks of gold and silver
every person who prays in this Masjid
every child that memorized the Quran you
will inshallah share in that reward
donate it now guys and do not delay
foreign